good morning john it's question tuesday
of the day that i answer real questions
from real nerdfighters and it's not
really tuesday and it's not really gonna
be me like the nerdfighters are real the
questions are real but am i real shuffle
is a podcast app and yes and thanks for
doing this i do have to say you should
check out their service i actually think
it'd be pretty cool if a lot of
nerdfighters used it for your hand and
john because you get to like react and
interact with the podcast with other
people kind of so
that might be cool but regardless the
point is that they have taken the
tremendous amount of transcripts of the
words that you and i have said john and
they have created an ai chat bot that is
a mash-up of the two of us which is
something else because sometimes you can
tell when it's you and when it's me and
so i'm doing a question tuesday but i'm
not answering the questions artificial
hank and john are rachel asks what
should i do about the creeping dread hmm
i i would recommend that you try to do
the thing that you need to do to reach
those goals then turn that dread into
excitement because you're about to go
for it i mean that one was me that one's
definitely me it sounds like good advice
is it probably not most of the stuff
that sounds like good advice isn't megan
wants to know do you play minecraft
minecraft minecraft minecraft minecraft
minecraft minecraft minecraft how many
socks are too many socks i don't know
12. this of all the things the ai said i
think is the most inaccurate i run a
sock subscription for charity there's no
such thing as too many socks you're
challenged to a duel what's the weapon
trampoline dodgeball i mean hell yeah
that yes oatmeal stan wants to know what
do you recommend to pass the time while
i recover from wisdom teeth removal i
would recommend that if you have had
wisdom teeth removed recently that
watching crash course videos at twice
speed is probably the best way to pass
the time is it like just after
anesthesia did you mean half speed
chicken fingers dipped in applesauce or
french fries dipped in frosty definitely
french fries dipped in something because
in any comparative tasting of applesauce
or french fries dipped in frosty the
fries are going to win every time i mean
with a very tiny exception that sounds
like exactly what i would say is there a
specific reason humans get so attached
to stuffed animals i think it's natural
selection i think as we've evolved to be
more social we've sort of developed the
need for that attachment through
activities like filmmaking music art
still forms of storytelling or you can
tell a story we got a little lost at the
end there but that is a vlogbrothers
vibe when eating a bicycle where should
one start i would venture to say the
handlebars first the spokes might try to
escape or rebel and the tire could
explode that there feels very uncanny
valley to me it's like it thinks it
knows what it's like to be a person but
it actually doesn't if you could turn
one person into a pelican who would it
be and why i'd like to turn prince harry
into a pelican because he can dance like
one i mean that's funnier than anything
i would have said
that's funnier than anything i would
have said favorite cursed item
nerdfighteria has turned into a meme oh
god i don't know that we've cursed any
specific item we discovered the train
song but we didn't realize that that was
cursed but that's cursed i don't know
for sure what train song the ai is
talking about here but i'm pretty sure
it's this one
[Music]
did i discover that no that kinda
rediscovered it though and it is i like
it and it is also cursed favorite social
media platform i like twitter a lot
because i get there first thing in the
morning and they blur the lines a bit
between what's news and what's
not news that actually made me feel a
little bit too seen
ai bot best pizza topping not a day has
gone by when i haven't thought wistfully
of the pepperoncinis and mushroom pizzas
that i used to eat while i lived in ohio
it remains in my brain as the perfect
marriage of pepperoni and fungus and
that's some hardcore john green vibes
for you right there and let's finish off
with one from peyton who asks what is
your new furby's name it's not named yet
so the ai gets to do it it's philip this
has been delightful if
a little unsettled and i was having kind
of a hard time figuring out how to end
this video but then i realized i could
just turn to the artificial intelligence
john
wear sunscreen i'll see you on tuesday